- Gordon Ramsay would fucking kill me.
- Well, he doesn't know it's good, so.
(groovy bass music)
So I'm on my way to McDonald's to pick up
the supplies for an
ice cream sandwich hack
that was blowing up on the Internet
where you take two cookies and a McFlurry
and you make a delicious
ice cream sandwich.
I'm gonna go get the supplies
and bring it back to my coworkers
to see if it lives up to the hype.
Have you heard of this viral tweet
about creating an ice cream sandwich
using a McFlurry and
two McDonald's cookies?
- That sounds like
something I would have done
when I was seven years old.
- I've never had either.
I've never had a McFlurry
or a McDonald cookie.
- You've never had a McFlurry?
- No.
- Cookies and ice cream?
Of course that's delicious.
- ♫ You want ice cream
♫ You want ice cream
- I have not heard about
that but it sounds delicious.
- A little nervous.
- Ice cream?
- I'm ready.
- Perfect for the summer time.
- Is this like Oreo?
- Yeah, it's Oreo.
- Oooh!
- Ugh!
- There's no wrong way though.
- [Interviewee] How has
no one done this before?
- Pretty simple.
Or is it?
- This is already a mess.
- It's not as easy to put
the McFlurry on the cookie
as I thought it would be.
- I already know this is
gonna be good, I mean,
it's fucking ice cream
and fucking cookies.
- I'm kinda pumped.
- [Interviewee] Beautiful!
- And it's dripping everywhere.
- Let me just clean it up a little.
(slurping)
(laughs)
- Mmm.
- Okay.
Pretty good.
- It's not half bad.
- Oh my god, this is delicious.
- Sure.
(chuckles)
- I mean, it tastes like McDonald's.
- You wanna "Lady and a Tramp" it?
- Sure.
- Okay.
- Fucking delicious, obviously.
(laughs)
- Good.
It's messy.
I should've put more McFlurry.
- Oh, that's pretty good!
- This is a lot of effort,
and look how much ice cream is coming out.
- I'm surprised that just like,
people are just finding
out about this now.
- I like to use my calories
on the things that are a little tastier
and, or, boozier.
- If you could toss it in the freezer
for like, two minutes.
- I'm gonna give it away, I think.
- Does anyone want this sloppy,
half eaten ice cream sandwich?
- I don't think we have any takers.
- It'd be awesome if like,
the cookie was warmer.
- Do you think it deserves
to have gone viral?
- I think it deserves to
be on a McDonald's menu.
- If you put fries in it,
cuz you know, people
dip fries and ice cream,
and then it might not
(gestures with hands)
- Different McDonald's snack.
Just take a cookie, dip
it into the McFlurry,
saves you the mess.
You're welcome.
- I'd do this all day.
Yeah, I don't care if
I'm lactose intolerant.